das ist eine mega voll okay gut scheiß
drauf ich werde jetzt ein cut machen
weil deine reaktion erwarten
alter macht er aus holz eine neue aber
dass er noch platz tim und ich hab mal
schief mitbekommen weil ich mode
aufgesammelt haben läuft warum warum ist
bei hellichten tag auch immer hinter mir
also ich habe noch einen link von dir
hier habe ich alles wieder geben ach so
und jetzt leuchtet das siehst du und
jetzt für alles scheißegal man fühlt
sich trotzdem nicht so fühlt sich die
red box nicht
ich habe glaube ich ein fehler gemacht
aber ich werde nichts mehr abbauen was
da oben wichtig ist ich hab zwar habe
ich mich vertan
es gibt alle anderen sind inputs und der
rest des output und so sammelt sich
jetzt also ein output und verletzt ist
alles input also meine beiden iron
fürsten darf lag vor euch letzte riesige
eingangstür machen es kam nichts sagen
das nicht ich weiß nicht wo ich deine
ranch in thun soll jetzt immerhin ich
weiß nicht wieso das ist immer dieser
typische creeper moment wo man denkt es
ist ja es ist schon tag und so und dann
auf einmal geht irgendwann irgendwo ein
kripomann sieg und versöhnlich aber dass
keiner da war diese sparte eine bed bugs
nicht so weil ein mädchen auch energie
auf kleinbusse
ich musste sich gleich speichern ja
amazon wird speichert sich
dieses beim solarpanel oben noch so ein
platzhalter da könntest du schön wenn
ich meinen diamond drilling ein tool das
gerät aufgeladen zu naja ok wieder raus
mit meiner energie energie also so viel
energie von mir das war ein witz mein
bett ist auch werner mussler setzen so
ne fette feste und traffic gemeinsamen
grenze
über eine stunde wie ich das sehe ja bei
mir auch schon ich würde sagen dass er
einfach warte ich wollte ich dich
solltet ihr das eben dann mach ich hatte
ja ich bin auch ich fahre jetzt noch
kurz den zug aber ab was das also den
zucker da brauch ich auch bald echt
nicht mehr als er fand sich also schnell
ist der wahnsinn
ja man wird so lange du dann aussortiert
zauber kommt damit geht nichts mehr
you made my day wirklich sehe ich schon
gleich wieder der gruppe in höhe
flugbehörde kulturbetrieb görlitz
gebuddelt
so kann ich nichts machen kommt irgendwo
so das erste zauber rezept feld gehen
vielleicht vom büchel einher dass ihr
vielleicht marvel erden 1 hatte ich
schon pfeilen vorstellt das verstehe ich
jetzt nicht ich kann meinen jetpack mit
elektrik verlusten mit dem anderen eben
darauf laden
du kannst dein jetpack in denen die
blackbox tun oder installer pendelt
dieser genau dass man sich ich würde dir
empfehlen dass auch direkt zu tun weil
wenn du allein bist dann dreht sich erst
ein jetpack auf und danach kommen wir
dass die energien die bedburg sonst im
mittel später einfach deine energie
opfer müssen wir den man ja nicht möchte
einmal ganz kurz jetlag testen jetzt
ihre hermine und wenn ich jetzt runter
falle da ist es egal du kriegst folglich
falsch an
ich glaube jetzt also ich habe schule
schule gebaut die nach unendlicher
haltbarkeit haben und die wo ich niemals
fall schaden kriege wie viel braucht man
da für jeden schuh zwei diamanten ein
obsidian und sechs eisen das heißt aus
vier diamanten 12 eisen zwei absichern
ja gut dann wird's erst mal nicht geht
geht aber noch gar keine diamanten von
daher noch gar keine
ich brauche im klorollen element wo
finde ich dass klorollen element
sogleich heute alles sortiert schön gold
april hier so das credo kammer machte
viele tweets ja für expect wollte ich
immer schon so die konjunktiv konya die
ihre wagen die ganz sicher kommt die er
wiederkommen werden
mach ich mir jetzt noch mal den
extractor 4trips maschinen glock ist
einfach nur rief anteil an gut okay also
irgendwie weniger fehler und probieren
weil ich nebenbei einfach nur sache
tauber aber wohl nicht werden
ich will ich habe das gefühl man muss
wirklich übrigens die krise ist noch bei
dir unten drin welches das lag im
extrakt doch jetzt gerät aber es ist
auch nicht so
ein echtes feineren und electrolux op
gut da warte ich noch ganz großem stil
und dann mache ich ganz kurz ein start
bzw and cut jetzt erstmal war jetzt habe
ich jeden tag oder wahrgenommen es
fertig ist fertig jetzt warte ich immer
noch und sagt bescheid weil ich probiere
ganze zeit noch aus na ja auch nicht
also ich habe echt ratlos gerade
vielleicht ist es eisen auch nicht
komisch klorolle der unterschied
zwischen zentrifugen generator und dem
anderen zentrifuge ist sozusagen das
erweiterte genau wie die hier jetzt die
erweiterten von dem sind aber die
brauchen ja stetig energie
das heißt dazu hätte müsste ich
wahrscheinlich mein ding noch ausbauen
sogar man kann in der wasserkraft bleibt
genau weil die ja nonstop energie festen
und die dürfen wir keine nicht keine
energie nicht keine richtig so ein paar
hier paar zafira nehme ich auch nicht
ich weiß was ich tun soll was braucht
eigentlich das ganze zuckerrohr
ich brauche das papier mit live-pause
jetzt nicht mehr als beute welches bald
abbauen
aber was ich hab das habe ich vielleicht
hier den strudel
nein
aber das schule wurde auch nicht
ausgeschlossen haben wir sehen
vielleicht hier workbench immer noch
robotic urology co unterwegs
was gibt mir magica ich glaube moos
stein gibt magic echt mega von loki gute
scheiß drauf ich werde jetzt ein cut
machen weil deine reaktion verfahren
wenn du auf einmal sind künftiger hab
ich das ding geworden weil einfach nur
deine reaktion hatten sogar von ihren
chefs mit den also ich muss mir
offensichtlich im harz nutzen dafür die
chance bringt das ist so verzaubern
mainzer immer klappt gut
ich schaue noch ganz heutig brauchen
noch ganz 14 den extrakt aber es dauert
nicht lang
ich habe jetzt immer ein weiteres im
zauber tool oder was ihr gast
freigeschaltet schauen wir das nochmal
ganz an und dann mache ich den schnitt
aber dann doch auf jeden fall was
freigeschaltet
si
kann ich mir ein bühne rolle
baden baden baden fahren habe ich
erfahren wo das kann man fahren kommen
natürlich auch gleich ihre von oder aus
so ich hab sofort fertig mit meinem mann
fahren herstellt und nicht
messeleiter so krieg wochen raus perfekt
da habe ich ganze gesucht jetzt habe ich
keine rolle mehr ob volvo ich die farbe
weiß ich ja glaube dass die zuschauer
zunächst ob das auch so funktioniert
dann allerdings fantastisch fantastisch
ist auch dass ich jetzt ein extractor
besitze sehr geil und dann würde ich
sagen möchte den cut leute bleibt geilo
im moment für diese mega die kinder
zusammen hoffe nicht dass eben noch also
mache ich mal sagen möchte für diese
mega folge wenn wir da keinen daumen
hoch weil die dann weiß ich auch nicht
ist so wir haben jetzt so lange
aufgenommen vor allem ich habe so viel
geschafft gibt einfach mal daumen hoch
wenn ihr findet das auch weiterhin so
sein soll weiterhin so konstruktiv vor
allem so miteinander agiert paar fell
situation mit drin also auch witzig
allerdings auch konstruktiv was gemacht
zum beispiel daniel etter und was alles
das wird uns auf jeden fall freuen was
macht er infiziert sein team wiederholt
dass man vergisst ja das ist voll
scheiße meine kuh wurde mir geklaut
leute wenn ihr den ihn wenn irgendein
findet er meine kuh gefördert und das
war halt wollt dann könnt ihr mir das
gerne auch einfach in die kommentare
schreiben
mir läuft ja alles der solar panel ist
weg ach so das ist einfach electric fall
ist aktuell noch mal kurze frage und
zwar wenn jetzt ja nacht ist dann
erzeugt solarpanel natürlich keine
energie
richtig allerdings die energie die er am
tag gespeichert hat schwarzarbeit box
okay das ist gut ansonsten wie gesagt
ein solarpanel ist mega sprach also noch
das erste briefing solche wie mache ich
das dann soll ich dann einfach
theoretisch könnte ist hier ja zum
beispiel an die drei seiten noch im
solarpanel machen oder du kannst es dir
gleich acht stufen bzw noch 7 und machte
dann gleich ein etwas panel dann das
heißt noch sieben weitere solarpanel
kraft sind dann genau sieben weiteren
hast du das low voltage solarpanel
braucht hier noch ein transformer der
ist aber ganz easy plus insgesamt acht
von solarpanels aber auch dann finde ich
schon krass hätte ich mir dann erst mal
gleich aufs spielen ausrechnen welche
ganze nähert sich dafür benötige welche
ganzen rohstoffe wenig dann wird das
dann die nächste mission sein freund und
dann will ich erstmal sagen können und
weitere tipps in die kommentare
schreiben ich fliege jetzt auch mal so
hoch wie der hier noch mal kleiner
überblick über die welt hier kannst du
auch dass hier etwas freunde es
entwickelt sich das entwickelt sich was
es war kein großes grundstück der ist
entwickelt sich was ich habe und ich
habe wirklich voll ein kleines
grundstück eigentlich schon ja richtig
günstig ja ich habe noch am anfang schon
gedachten nimmt ein relativ großes
grundstück also ich finde mein
grundstück relativ gut sortiert bisher
alt wird allerdings noch ein haus drauf
kommen er wehrt wird alles in zukunft
komme ich habe richtig bock einfach und
dann würde ich erst mal sagen alter die
blumen verbreiten sie sich diesen viele
solche bei mir
volksstimme die ihn verbreiten alles
eine bietet fertig okay das werde ich ja
noch ganz schnell waren das bringt ihr
dauert aber nur kurz eine sekunde können
wenn ich zum inventar wie viele wald ja
kultivierter prinzessin beatrice
genau das kultivierte prinzessinnen
pac-man electric jetpack einfach hier
rein erbittert wahrscheinlich nächste
folge schon wieder aufgeladen sein
er warte bringt es mir wenn ich das in
der black box pack oder mehr und
solarpanel jacke wie hose doch eine
energiequelle also bestimmt wenn du das
dann noch ein paar koffer käme ich habe
hier so viel fertig okay ich habe ganz
schnell wieder recht schnell so alles
einsortieren vier honig habe ich jetzt
noch in der hand und dann will ich auch
sagen bleibt geilo wir sehen uns in der
nächsten folge private da mache ich mir
doch ganz schnell koffer käme das geht
ja total schnell jetzt hier sowohl abla
dauert höchstens etwas ich sekunde noch
eine verabschiedung jetzt hier sogar
stapo ich habe den finger in mexiko okay
dass man soll hier zwar bereits fokus -
dreimal schwarzer kater ich schaue mir
bei meinen gürtel vorbei die arbeit
bestimmt doch stehen fleißig fleißig so
sofa sitzende stunde und 15 minuten ja
ok aber ich bin jetzt fertig das heißt
freunde ihr wisst alles was wir vorhin
gesagt haben ich will dann einfach jetzt
noch kommt zum ende sagen wir sind dann
beim nächsten mal wieder nächste folge
morgen oder halt heute abend noch ich
weiß es nicht
so ist es und bis dann zschau